are you fulfilled with the life that
you're living and if you're not well
then are you do you have the guts to go
out and make some changes that's it yeah
I mean that's like even when I look at
myself and retiring at 36 and it's like
do you have the guts to go I am not into
it anymore I'm not happy
[Music]
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is tony and frances
Pappalardo and they own a company called
customize your life which look I met
them as a on a friend basis on a
vacation and they were just like the
coolest most easygoing positive people
that you just want to be around and then
I found out about this super cool
business that they started and it's
about helping people from the inside out
and outside and it's everything from
finances to how are your relationships
so it's kind of looking at business from
a 360 perspective of all the things that
could affect it in a negative way and
then on the positive side it's about
setting goals about what you truly want
from life and they have really great
strategies on that so we doand to all
the things pertaining to business and
then we talked a lot about life and the
challenges as human beings but
ultimately to think positive and think
about what you want not what you don't
want and then you'll manifest it so we
had a really good time I hope you enjoy
it
[Music]
Frances and Tony Pappalardo thank you so
much for coming yeah um I'm excited to
talk to you guys about your business and
about your big vision for people and
your sort of revolutionary approach to
helping people figure things out not
always from the outside in but the
inside out so you have a company called
customize your life which I'd like to
talk about second first off I want to
understand how you arrived at this
company and so maybe tell me a little
bit about you know a little bit about
your story and how you came to the
conclusion that this is a great company
and maybe in the middle of it kind of
how you met and just made this awesome
Union and partnership that makes this
great company sure baby sure man so
where to begin I mean that you know for
both of us we were sort of at a point
when we met each other that we were
looking for something beyond traditional
wisdom everything that traditional
wisdom had taught us about living our
life in terms of really doing what the
masses do then becoming a mass-produced
standardised person necessarily of
society we were looking to create
different results we really kind of
wanted to figure out how we could
maximize our resources so we could
experience life at another level
the only challenge with that is neither
one of us had experience and how to do
that so we had this idea of what we
wanted we had this vision my background
was in performance I moved to New York
for musical theater I had gone through
some situations I lost my dad and that
was really my turning turning point so
to want to create different results you
know and he had a sort of a different
upbringing that that brought him to that
point as well but for the two of us
that's really what it was about
you know we wanted to be able to live
life on our terms we wanted to be able
to just not have to go through the
traditional groupthink tradition
traditional wisdom of society that that
we had done to that point and be able to
travel be able to contribute at higher
levels be able to really do the things
or kind of kept in the cobwebs of our
souls so to speak that kind of freaked
us out and scared us and we finally got
to a point where we were like you know
what let's no let's freakin do this I
believe we have the audacity now to say
we can't we can you know and that's
really what set us on our path that's
what set us to finding mentors and Tony
actually had already had some really
good relationships when we met that were
really valuable in helping us unlock
this and figure this out and that's
really all it came down to for us to be
able to do this was mentorship yeah I
didn't want to have to be the guy to
figure everything out I think popping is
a lot better so many people there live
imitation is the highest form of
flattery yeah well I mean when you think
of coaching you know obviously you being
professional racecar driver I mean you
had professional coaches all throughout
your career coaching on how to drive a
car better so when we looked at life we
said okay who's got the results that we
want who's got you know not just I'm not
talking about just just materialistic
things I'm talking about like who has
the family life that we want it was a
time with their their kids their wife
you know we kept seeing as we grew up
both Francis and I we kept seeing people
spend all their time chasing this career
but then losing their family hmm all
right and so we were like I don't want
to do that and you know my dad and mom
had gone through a lot of challenges
financially on the furniture business
went out of went out of business you
know had some real challenging
situations with family loss law money
and millions of dollars in debt and it
was the greatest thing that happened to
our faith which is you know at the time
please explain yeah at the time yeah
they certainly didn't feel that way I
didn't feel that way this started happen
when I was about 10 years old and I'm
you know house got foreclosed on cars
repossessed so you know when you see the
stress of not having money and I'm
certainly not saying money is everything
but when you don't have money it puts
tremendous pressure on the family
structure and the kids see it and sense
it no matter how much our parents tried
to hide us in
shield us from it we knew things weren't
right when when furniture was being sold
out of the house yeah when you lose your
bed yeah and you're like yeah here's a
who's a sleeping bag yeah you knew it
wasn't a sleepover yeah keep talking
about all these fun games your appliance
isn't funny anymore like candles the
power didn't go out I saw you flip the
switch
well the neighbors houses have lights
like understanding this your mom would
actually do that she'd play games you
guys sure she did it oh wow yeah and my
sister was younger I hate to admit it
but you know my sister's five and a half
years younger um you know what was
joking around about that but but she's
more mature than you she's always she's
awesome
she really is great and my
brother-in-law is my best friend he's
such a great guy you know but you know
when we were going through this it I
heard a long time ago from one of our
mentors you said look the the seeds of
an equal or much greater benefit lie
within every great adversity okay and
the challenge is is most of the time we
get so wrapped up in the university and
it's not like what are we supposed to
learn from this you know how are we
supposed to grow how are we supposed to
change so my dad started to look and he
started to just seek mentorship seek
opportunities seek stuff and he met a
guy that had retired in his early 30s
around 30 to 33 his wife retired at 28
and he started to pursue him and this
guy started to take him under his wing
and coach him and help him really
develop some businesses and taught him
about not just business but about life
about having a good marriage like this
got really coached my dad in life first
coach yeah like all of life exactly and
and what he said to him he said look
Vinny if you're not gonna allow me to
coach you in life I'm not gonna coaching
business because your life is probably
the way your life is Vinny you're gonna
screw up any business that I help you
develop so this is the seeds for what
was passed on to you because that's what
customized your life is about is about
looking at the full spectrum of your
life including your business and your
personal relationships with you know
your partner or your family
so that's that's fantastic and you have
heard another great thing you were
talking about he people have adversity
they tend to focus on that and that's
that's what they get more unsent let's
talk about this right whatever you focus
on you get more of its like water the
right plants so he wanted more
opportunity he wanted something
different so he started seeking those
things instead of thinking only about
the problems you know only think about
the problems only get more of the
problem yes 100% got it so then what was
the next step like how did you birth the
idea of this business well you know what
happened was was I start a basic
framework of the business is very unique
and you've explained it to me an
in-depth and I'm like please explain
more but it's it's very creative but
very innovative and and obviously you
know some what came from from your dad
so bless him well what we saw we saw a
gap so I started getting mentored at 22
all right and and what it was still kind
of um it wasn't as organized as it was
kind of like hey talk to this guy if you
need help with this talk to that guy you
need help with this so what we did was
over time and I got great results with
it and at 22 I started working with my
dad with this gentleman Charlie and we
started to develop our business and we
leveraged companies online alright the
internet was up-and-coming they had done
everything offline so a lot of companies
do network marketing Amazon does it Bay
does it where when you sit well we
talked about leveraging a company what
you're doing is you're leveraging you're
utilizing their infrastructure so
they're warehousing they're shipping
they're receiving all that so they just
had a way more per fret or professional
approach to leveraging companies rather
than the kind of rinky-dink hey I'm
gonna go sell some stuff on eBay you
know they knew how to scale and they
knew how to take it to a big big level
so that's they really professionalized
it so as time went on we said man this
is this is so helpful how do we scale it
how do we make this available for the
masses how do you say it you mean the
opportunity exactly
so that's but how did you develop that
as like book like how did you go did you
just say hey we want to help people or
did you say we're gonna start a company
it's called this this is our framework
or was it just the idea that you wanted
to help
really more the idea well first we
started to get helped and we had so many
areas of our life changing develop and
grow and then it kind of birthed out of
that we were like we want to help people
we want to get so really float this
wasn't like a this wasn't a and then B
it was like a free-flowing kind of like
oh this is great and that's great and
while we could help with okay let's go
okay great like I love flowing it's yeah
like we've talked about before you know
the the best stuff is when you get out
of the way and kind of let things take
their natural course so by by example by
seeking by you know whether it be you or
your dad or you know the the flow of it
all all of a sudden you arrive finally
after some time at this place really oh
wait this is a business yep yep yeah and
that honestly like all of those pieces
came together first and then the name
came second okay it just made sense this
is what we're doing here I mean we were
you know since we've been able to
establish our assets and get ourselves
in a position where we're really living
the life that we're proud of the one
that we'd always dreamt of and of course
we're still expanding and growing and
going beyond as we're looking and
helping other people were like this is
we're teaching people how to customize
their life mm-hmm we had a vision for
what we wanted our life to look like and
we've been able to get pretty close to
it now with the help of the experts that
we've sought out credible experts that
we've sought out that it helped us
maximize on the areas of relationships
finances which are the two main buckets
that people need help with right
creating self-awareness and then other
areas that we needed help maximizing and
now we're here and we're helping other
people do the same thing and we're like
that's that's what we do you know it's
about creating a life that you
intentionally design not one that you
just kind of go with you know societal
flow and hope works out and think you
know gosh maybe you know 20 30 40 years
down the road go how did I end up here
you know so many people are chasing and
climbing this proverbial ladder but
nobody's really saying what what does
this ladder leaned up against do I even
want to go there yeah what's not from
passion your passion was to live the
life you wanted you know and then you
realize other people want to do the same
thing
this is how we can help them do this so
so say I'm you know say I'm Danica
Danica brand and I have something that
you know I have a company and I come to
customize your life and I'm like I want
you to help me what happens next it
depends on the areas that you need to
grow in right most people that come to
us they come to us pretty organically
we're not really out there heavily
soliciting and things like that they
they come through referrals of people
who received good results and that's
what's shared with them and they'll hear
you know we've heard we've received some
great things in terms of how to pay off
debt we've heard great things about how
you guys help people you know start an
asset that could out produce more cash
flow for them we've heard great things
about how you've helped people
relationally so everybody has a
different yeah so everybody has a
different thing that they're looking to
work on and that's really where we help
them
okay create a blueprint towards the
goals that they set for themselves okay
so what's the process like like is there
a quick overview of the process that you
go through with these companies yeah we
we basically interview them so in most
cases again it's not all cases but in
most cases somebody's you know it's hurt
our name or you know reached out to us
or reached out to somebody that we're
connected with and we'll take them
through an interviewing vetting process
where we you know we find out really
what they're looking for it's the
typical thing that attracts them to us
is typically the finances yeah all right
they want to make money and thinking
about their business yeah and so they're
going you know hey I have a job my wife
has a job we have a couple kids but we
don't have enough time we need to come
up with some assets so we then teach
them how to develop some low cost
startup assets online
all right primarily with a network
marketing business so we say okay cool
this is the first asset that we're gonna
be able to help you develop but in the
process of that we want to help you get
your finances in order all right we want
to teach you how to budget I want to
teach you because so many people today
it's like it's like the person that wins
lotto right and it's like they have all
this money but they have terrible
spending habits sure and then end up
being more broke because they spend all
their money and they just have access to
credit or whatever good that all his
money yeah so it doesn't and we see with
professional athletes
with all sorts of people that have a
large sum of money come in you know at
one time so we want to teach him good
foundational habits in their
relationships and their finances like
Francis was saying those are the two
buckets that people typically don't
really ever get any good coaching with
like I was getting relationship advice
from all my divorced friends friends
that were single you know so it was like
you know what should I do in this
relationship and everybody would have an
opinion you know but meanwhile they
didn't have any of the results it's like
me giving you advice on driving you know
but we do that so much of the time like
logically in sports we go okay if I want
to play basketball I'm gonna get
coaching from yeah that play baskerville
but in life we get coaching typically
from people that are terrible at
relationships
and terrible with their finances so we
really start on a basic level with
people and say look you gotta be willing
to let up let us help you in these areas
because any business we help you develop
you're gonna ruin it if you don't handle
your life properly you know and that's
really been the game changer and we
start really from the beginning where we
ask somebody a simple question which my
mentor has asked me a long time ago
where they said look they said what's
the question that you get asked your
whole life which is how do you what do
you wanna be when you get older what do
you wanna be and we said doctor fireman
lawyer whatever and you know it's the
wrong question the right question is is
how do you want to live amen
what do you want to let forget about
career forget about job forget about any
of that if you could I don't know have
100 million a half a billion whatever
the number is how would your life look
what would you do on a daily basis how
would you give to charity how much time
would you spend with family what kind of
schools would you send your kids to you
know what would you and your wife do
instead of having you know trying to
squeeze life into nights and weekends
when you're dead tired what would your
life look like with your spouse you know
like all these questions and then you
know anytime we ask somebody that their
brain you start to see like things
firing in their brain they're going oh
my gosh my whole
would be different you know and you go
okay well if that's the case you need to
figure out a vehicle that could then
produce the life that you want so mine
asking the right question I mean you
know you say that and we've talked about
school before and kind of the
institution and the structure and the
curriculum even but you know it's like
almost like we're ingrained into this
process where it's like 9:00 to 5:00 all
week we do things we don't want to do
and that's just normal it's like what if
you just like stopped all of that [ __ ]
and just said what do I really want to
do right how do I really want to live my
life would I take trips would I be an
artist would I you know would I go what
I learned some people want to live older
I get the more I want to learn some
thought some of it has to do with
learning so that's an incredible first
steps is saying you know how do you want
your life to look and there's so many
people that just buy into this rat race
this like her to say like the human race
it's like a race to no finish line yeah
a race to death that sucks you know I
mean that's just not that much fun to
just you know you know go to work to
live and you sound like you live to work
then yeah right so what happens after
they start going oh I would do this I
would do that I would do that I'm afraid
if I actually answered that question I
would probably just stop working and I
just live and have a garden and a
hundred dogs in camp of course yes we
love camping yeah anyway we've
customized your life it's not about just
making enough money sir than you could
sit at home and just do nothing or or
whatever it's about like what is your
life gonna mean yeah like when you know
when you pass away yeah like are people
gonna remember you because you left a
mark like where people's lives better
off because you truly lived yeah really
legacy oh my gosh legacy is so much what
we talked about yeah because look I got
scared at like seven eight years old I
went down to Florida for my grandparents
like the retirement home community thing
and I and I literally remember this as
clear as day being around 78 years old
and going this is what everyone works
hard for to play shuffleboard in the
afternoon I guess the question is is
like are you fulfilled with the life
that you're living and if you're not
well then are you do you have the guts
to go out and make some changes that's
it yeah I mean that's like even when I
look at myself and retiring at 36 and
it's like do you have the guts to just
say I don't want to do that anymore even
though that's all you know that's you
know where you it's your reputation it's
your identity it's safe it's familiar
it's like do you have the guts to go I
am NOT into it anymore
yeah I'm not happy yeah yep do you see
people having lots of big life changes I
do see people yeah okay absolutely I
mean light bulbs start to go off left
and right and when they start to strip
away these conventional ideas that
they've accepted for so long that this
is what life has to be about now we
start flipping the paradigm in their
mind and they yeah they start breaking
through their own mental barriers and
thinking well oh my gosh I could add I'm
actually really starting to connect I
think with the thing that I'm supposed
to do and maybe it's that's not the
thing that's gonna make them money it's
maybe they're supposed to just you know
maybe they really just always wanted to
be a better well-rounded person in terms
of being a better mom a better citizen
in their community a better you know a
better wife a better you know they
wanted to travel they wanted to do all
these things it doesn't have to be about
the thing that makes you money mm-hmm
right and that's where society gets so
confused and our identity becomes what
we do yeah the first question we know a
party is always what do you do what do
you do and then the whole conversation
thereafter becomes about that and so
when we go to parties we like to fun
with that question people ask us right
away what do you do and like oh my gosh
tree I we do so many things
let's see we'd like to what we're
pronounced we do a lot of things with
our kids we have two kids we love to
surf we ski sometimes we and we do yoga
we do a lot of stuff with charities and
things we you know causes that we care
about and believe in was there and we
just kind of need them gorse and they go
how do you do all that yeah yeah and and
they they sort of they get like
the googly eyes you know like you know
and what kind of leaned in and say I'm
sorry did you mean how do we make money
mm-hmm like oh yeah all right well
that's that's fairly simple but that's
probably the least most interesting part
about us hmm right because life is in
art and our our belief system is that
life is meant to be lived so then it
comes about answering that question well
how do I get myself in a financial
position to do that which is where we
help people you start to clean up their
financial behavior and solve some things
I can get them there but that's really
what it you know it comes down to
purpose and fulfillment which isn't
meant to be confused with happiness I
think our today's generation is
continually trying to find this
happiness like I just want to be happy
and they they'll find that it's a target
that just keeps moving they never seem
to hit it whereas we're saying no like
you know do do something that brings you
fulfillment mm-hmm which comes from a
much deeper place within true right
there's a difference between like you
know having the dogs and like relaxing
and things like that and then you know
setting a goal to inspire people or to
help your local community or you know
help your community get you know you
know like if I love gardening fresh
local fruits and but you know you're so
you go and you can have a garden but
it's really about you know helping serve
your community so it's going a little
deeper into how are you gonna make a
difference so the question really
becomes to you know everyone is how do
you want to be remembered mm-hmm yeah
you know how do you want people to look
back at you and say please describe
Francis you know how you know how you
you know yeah how would you be described
as an adventurous person fun you know
like that should be kind of the question
and then you reverse it back from there
is like what are they gonna say yeah and
my funeral it's funny we're actually in
the process of writing a book right now
it'll be called customize your life and
then the first chapter
beyond the introduction starts with your
funeral come in there you go
and it's a visualization exercise where
we're just inviting the reader into sort
of this you know experiences if they're
at their own funeral and they could see
the highlight reel of what's going on
and in the people's minds that are
passing by and paying their respects
what would they see what do they want
them to see right and then what's the
gap in between versus like who are you
today versus the potential of who you
really could be and to me the saddest
thing in the world would be going to my
grave not having filled that gap right
of who I was to the to the ultimate
potential of who I could be you know and
so we we start them there and then we
the whole part of the whole purpose of
chapter 1 in the book is to begin with
the end in mind mm-hmm is to start there
start with that vision yeah really think
it through not just an material you know
the material world in a sense of yes you
might want to leave a financial legacy
and we think that's great and we you
know we we believe in taking care of the
first few generations you know beyond us
but and as you're saying Danica your
your values your virtues she you know
your truths you know as your grandchild
passing by they're saying you know man
grandma she always she always stuck to
her guns you know she's like a gladiator
in high heels she just always stood for
what she believed in and she made sure
we did the same thing you know so that
value that virtue is integrity mm-hmm is
what you're hearing you know are they
saying oh you know grandpa he just you
know he always did the right thing he
always had the courage to do this and
that you know what are those types of
things that you're hearing and is that
who you are today is it reflective of
who you are today most people aren't
truly living out of their values today
yeah and that's something we help people
define as well and then charge them with
the accountability because that's what
they came to us for is accountability to
really be truly acting out of that place
which comes which then what they're
doing is they're reaching their true
authenticity which as you know brené
Brown says the only way you can really
truly feel connected to the world as if
you're coming from an authentic place
no I've totally have a new thought for
you guys
scratch trying to help people when they
have a business you need to be like
ground zero for kids before they before
they go to college before they go waste
a bunch of time and money on something
they really don't give a [ __ ] about like
like you know the general like degrees
that they get because they get to go be
enough a sorority or fraternity maybe
and they're not really sure yet instead
go like start from out of high school
and you know there needs to be some some
some some part of the curriculum needs
to be customized your life these are the
questions we need to be asking ourselves
you know before we embark on a financial
burden that you pay off for the next
thirty years or just you know continuing
on this repetitious we love like I do
things I don't like to do and right not
spending the time to think about what it
is that you actually want to do right
for me I a couple years ago I finally
had the time so like slow down I was
alone a lot more often and had a lot
less to do when I was not at the track
and I figured out much more about Who I
am and what I like to do but lord knows
some peace and quiet is not easy to come
by these days
sure yeah but it's it's so necessary and
that's really that's really when you can
get to know yourself yeah you know and
and so you know it's funny you're
talking about eighteen year olds
launching into the world and
unfortunately in most cases taking on a
lot of debt because they don't have that
figured out yeah an 80 plus percent of
them not actually working in the field
that they graduated in it's not a good
equation that is that right just think
that's decision yeah I don't know the
exact but I know it's above 80 percent
and it's wow that's you know a friend of
ours said you're asking an 18 year old
unregulated bag of testosterone what he
wants to do with them you know and he
says how many of you you know would
would invest into an eighteen year old
you know and he describes it that way
unregulated back it says so yeah there
was like no a he's like you won't give
him twenty thousand no eighty thousand
no
doesn't no no that's like that's but
that's what you're doing when you maybe
give them a little bit in a backpack
alright passport and then take off into
the world and go experience some things
go see the world go go figure out what
it is that you truly love and places
that I like you don't just stay in one
place and yeah I agree or at least just
hand them some really tough questions
you know start with that end of the game
you know end of the life visualization
and see get it just get them thinking
through a different filter yeah you know
well yeah I guess I was probably 19 18 I
wasn't in college yet I never went to
college but I was about ready to enroll
in college and one of my my dad had
actually connected me with another guy
and mentor guy looked up to he said so
uh so you're going on you're gonna go to
college and I said yeah I think I'm
gonna go to college he goes why yeah I
was like wow and I had no just chuck it
well and that's what he I mean basically
after some back and forth he's I was
like yes fine I just want a party I just
want to hang out I just want to serve I
just want to about what to do you're
like no those days fun so I keep going
sorry no no but that's exactly what it
was he goes why are you gonna spend six
figures taking out loans doing all this
stuff he goes just go surf just go party
just go do whatever he goes but don't
you know put on a whole bunch of debt
because you quote-unquote are you're
trying to you know get into this college
world because everybody has told you to
do it he doesn't it's really just an
excuse me to go survey those just go
surf and it yeah he was such a simple
little thing but like one of the things
that we coach young people about if we
typically won't bring somebody on that's
18 19 20 because they're just kind of
too young too immature but if we a lot
of times parents will say hey can you
talk to my my kid you know they're
thinking about doing this with college
and we don't have enough money to pay
for their college so can you talk to me
because I think I'm not taking all these
loans
they're gonna have six plus figures of
college debt and you know and that's one
of the simplest things we ask the person
is they what do you want to you know how
do you want your life to look you know I
don't know I never thought of it that
way okay well before you spend all this
money on a college degree yeah you know
why don't you go - why don't you just go
to a local community college for a
couple years kind of figure some stuff
out and then if you still want to go to
the major university and still then you
can do it but at least you saved a whole
bunch of money you know and yes okay you
maybe missed out on the experience for a
couple years but I'll tell you what I
visited all my friends at college I
acknowledge yeah and I just I just spent
the money for the weekend I'm not
recommending that anyone but the point
was was is I didn't need to spend a
whole bunch of money and a lot of people
don't need to spend a whole bunch of
money for quote unquote experience it's
the honorable way to burn time yep
right isn't it I'm not saying everybody
dies by any means look if I'm going to
the doctor's office I sure as hell hope
you went to college for that lawyers
they need to know the information they
need to learn how to speak a different
language so I don't understand them
anymore
that's supposed to be a joke but I mean
that some of some things you do need to
go to school and you you you know go do
that yeah but there's so much of it
that's about you know doing what some
respected which is go to college when
what should be respected is honesty of
like I don't know what I want to do
right I would rather take some time go
travel something like that then spend
your money mom and dad yep and I mean
look at the like can you imagine how
much credibility that earn with the kid
and the parents what a mature kind of
decision to make and then you know come
a couple years later after traveling
around it but your parents will still be
willing to help you with something you
know yeah but college is just at least
something that you want then truly as I
just - you know this is like the you
know I try not to say things that are
very one-sided but it's like you know
you got a question the marketing degree
right yeah it's cool now like I'm gonna
go for marketing because they just don't
know yeah you know
oh absolutely so some of the degrees
that people haven't yeah that's what you
spend a hundred K for yeah so you spend
200 K for yeah wait a second you spend a
hundred K you gain 20 pounds
you killed some brain cells wait that's
a talent that is a talent don't touch
that I don't know I'm that's what I
learned visiting my friends in school
and I was that's your takeaway yeah
sorry I did I didn't they weren't
offering me yeah yeah so you have a
little girl
you obviously have Vincent who's a
little older yep um so you know what do
you feel how do you feel about how
you're going to address this wonderful
perspective with them it's a good
question so since we've already yeah
we've already been talking to him about
it you know we said look you know school
is a great option for you if that's what
you want to do the whole question is
what do you want to do with your life
and music see 60 16 yeah we've got him
thinking this way he sees that I mean I
I see value in school as well in terms
of experience as we were saying before
it's all just responds ability yeah
absolutely you learned some good skills
you know but it's again it's the it's
the weighing out of do I have the
resources does this make sense for the
end result that I'm trying to get right
it shouldn't just be this is what
everybody does we have Hazard Lee go
through this and oops
right now I'm saddled with all this debt
so Vincent because of the resources
we've we have is abled he has the
opportunity to go to school if he wants
to and we'll help him with that and he
knows that but we're very we're very
specific with him cuz he says look I
just you know I want to create a life
like you guys I want to have businesses
you know I just you know he's a family
man I want to have a wife I want to have
kids I want to be a family man that's
Vincent so okay in order to do that you
know you're gonna have to learn some
responsible skills and you know if you
want to if he wants to go to college and
study something study something that's
going to be useful for the rest of your
life right whether that's accounting
skills or communication skills whatever
it is you know don't just
at this for the social experience yeah
social experience is good it's merited
you know we talk to him a lot about
networking and building connections and
and creating friendships with people so
that because that that's essentially how
we've developed our success system our
parents this happen anyway threader
college and I'm plenty social yeah we
tell him don't be that guy you know
don't be that guy that you know nobody
wants to connect with after college keep
in mind you know you're building your
reputation there so we talked to him
about a lot of this stuff and it really
comes down to the order of consequences
that's kind of how we parent we get them
everything we get him to really play out
every action he's gonna do and get to
the furthest consequence and see if
that's something he really wants so
whether it's college whether it's
whatever whether it's partying we're
like hey look you could you can go drink
you're gonna be out of our house you do
whatever you want try whatever you want
what's the first consequence first
consequence is it's probably gonna be
really fun you're gonna have a great
time first consequence of anything
negative is usually probably really fun
right what a fun way to look at it right
I love this keep going but what's the
second and the third okay right let's
say you you know you want to try some
sort of hard drug that's easily
addictive right and people can ruin
their lives over it first consequence
really fun second not so cool
third life's starting to go down the
tubes and this this was not so we always
get him to project it out get to the
third and say is it worth it yeah right
anything he does whether that's going to
college it's you know hey he's buying
his first car yeah he just turned 16 he
wants to wait another year we've we've
told him he'll work and whatever money
he earns will match it okay and then but
he's responsible for the insurance he's
responsible for the maintenance all of
it
so he has to factor that into the money
so he's he's really logically thinking
through exactly what he wants to do and
and which car he wants and why you know
because for us it's not about what even
with schooling we're not so concerned
about him getting an A+
cuz he's an you know he's in school
right now it's are you learning are you
progressing you know he's got a tough
teacher right now or
good what are you learning from that all
right how are you thinking through this
how are you navigating the relationship
with her so you can get you know your
desired result right our toughest
teachers come here about our absolutely
yeah whether they be a parent or a
teacher itself yeah it's a parallel to
life right mm-hmm well so many people
today are so weak with the youth that's
coming out look you did not get let me
talk about this what's this is I'm
getting fired up about this let's go
we're done talking about the business
let's talk about how to solve the
world's primary have a daughter we want
to protect her
we want to make sure that she's okay not
even two so yeah yeah you know there's a
long time before you you know you've got
you've got it you get some more sometime
yeah what the reality is is that she is
gonna learn you learned we've learned
through the tough parts of life not
through being coddled right no you know
you weren't carried onto the racetrack
and said hey here's a racecar go drive
it you'll be great good luck
like you know you had to grind it out
yeah my first time in a go work and
crashed my usual
I went head-on into a concrete wall dad
screwed up the brakes and they failed no
I'm really being mean I'm sorry I love
you dad you're wonderful mechanic but
the truth is the brakes failed and I
went straight on into a wall and he said
you want to keep going like yeah see but
that's the difference yep see a lot of a
lot of parents would have said oh my
gosh these will never have to do this
yeah I'm so sorry and just pulled you
away and now that starts to develop a
fear rather than a strength right so you
learned at a young age how to press in
to the things that were uncomfortable
right so we talked to Vincent and
obviously as Emma gets all the will talk
to her about this as well but we say
look there's there's good fear you know
and then there's bad fear all right like
a good fear is like hey a strange guy is
following you it's you know at night
it's dark like okay oh the accurate one
exactly exactly okay run but then like a
fear with with stretching yourself like
when something is uncomfortable yeah
getting something and it's like what our
look your brain is wired for for you to
go towards the path of least resistance
well sure you know so it's like that's
like when something's not coming so to
protect you
exactly so that's when you need to press
into it
all right that's when you need to go
okay what am I supposed to learn here
how is this supposed to stretch me and I
think if I mean at least with us that
has been so great with Vincent that
anytime he's come to a tough point his
life we push him and nudge him and get
him to think about things and go all
right
this is tough it's supposed to be tough
yeah this is how you grow simple as
example is working out sure you know
like like it's you know pain there's no
don't growth pain absolutely
we felt that today that muscle soreness
yeah today tomorrow right working out is
like a great example I use that to where
you're not going to get stronger unless
you stress the muscle yeah right you're
not gonna have better cardio until you
stress your system until you you know
make your lungs uncomfortable right it
is same thing with your mind it's the
same thing with you know a new skill set
and and you know just with with parents
today if they would understand that and
stop trying to protect their kids so
much and just let the kids be buried in
the phone and in social media and all
these ride our bike everyone yeah you
know you just you just went on your bike
and rode off and now it's like I mean I
probably would be guilty of that of the
of the of the paranoia of going too far
myself like you know you get worried I
get worried about my dogs being outside
for too long without me watching them
like a helicopter parent that they're
gonna run away so but truth be told
Huskies want to run away so I don't have
to do so I'm justifying myself but yeah
you you you know you the
days of freedom and also the things like
you know you're hearing about kids in
the old days they used to do crazy stuff
and jumps and jumping off of you know
their house into the pool and all kinds
of stuff and right now it's like I feel
like there's such a your wings get
clipped and everybody's afraid of I mean
shoot you might be afraid your neighbor
saw it and call social services on you
that you're not being a responsible
parent hey you left your kids out back
too long yeah they were digging a hole
yeah you know no it's a hundred percent
right and that's where order of
consequence on the reverse is is look if
the first thing you do is really hard
and really tough and it really pushes
you and stretches you yeah well yeah
that's uncomfortable but the second
order of consequence of that is is a
positive result comes out of it such as
working out yeah working out if you
don't like to work out and you've never
worked out in your life the first time
you go to the gym is gonna suck right
and but then the the the second order
and the third or in the fourth or you
start to get in shape yes sir to feel
better stuff yeah lose weight your your
the quality of your life improves yeah
so all these positive notes come out of
when something is difficult and it's
right there's a pressure and the
pressure turning something into a
diamond you know yeah right I mean it's
just it takes that kind of discomfort we
were talking about this yesterday about
how you know even with emotional trauma
and how it's so important to to go
through the pain of really feeling it
and I think as as humans again just like
we were talking about with you take the
path of least resistance you naturally
the same thing that that applies to our
emotions and how we don't want to face
the difficult stuff yeah we don't want
to say the things out loud that that we
don't want to become real but we need to
start saying them out loud we need to
feel the emotion and you know the story
I told you yesterday about you know for
me last year having such discomfort with
like uprooting again packing my bags and
leaving and for two days my stomach is
in a knot like I can't eat and I can't
figure out what it is but I I'm leaving
in two days that's the only thing that
is going to happen and I finally
realized the night before I laughed at
through like just sending a text message
where I was like oh my god that's it I
said something about like you know I'm
sick of like start you know like
uprooting and always going and moving
and leaving and being the one to go and
all of a sudden like I cried it out I
was like in convulsions and I like got
through that emotion and let it come
through me
I wrote my journal and I woke up the
next morning and I pegged out and felt
great yeah but it was just like you know
our pain our our emotions can manifest
within us physically - and that's a
dangerous thing so if we're not prepared
to not only feel pain doing pushups like
how the hell are we ever gonna you know
deal with the pain of something that
happened in our childhood that was
painful or something that someone said
to you that was hurtful I mean how many
things can we say came from our you know
younger days that we can remember of
course whatever that age is four or five
years old maybe we start remembering but
stuff that happened to us in our teenage
years where you're like you never
freakin forgot what that one dude said
to you you never forgot what that one
lady said or you never forgot what your
dad said you know that stuff sticks with
you and so facing all of those things is
part of our healing yep and there's no
growth unless there's pain I always say
there's no there's always pain before
growth yeah and what about all the stuff
that you could be missing out on you
know like you know if you're not willing
to stretch yourself or push yourself to
go into that interview or should work
out the way that you know you want to
work out what what else in life are you
missing out on sure you're missing out
on the milestones you know 1015
milestones down the road of again your
fullest potential you know the greatest
things that you're meant to do on this
planet yeah and the mark that you're
supposed to leave and the things you're
gonna get to experience along the way
which could be really beautiful and and
and great I mean I think about the the
things that we get to experience now I'm
so thankful for all the discomfort then
we've had along the way and we've
learned to recognize discomfort like
we've learned to recognize it as a good
thing and welcome it yeah look you know
it's a total like you're an alchemist
you're just turning something that's
seemingly dangerous into an opportunity
you just and so there's also another way
to describe it is just just purely
change your perception yeah right we're
all just some point of awareness in the
universe of like where we put it right
we like we're pointing putting our point
of awareness on something so I shall get
more of that we are that you know right
like so put your point of awareness on
the positive side of something and I'm
preaching to myself right now but I'm
human and I think they were out through
those phases and so for myself I used to
be I used to be much more negative like
and I used to be much more you just like
I just wasn't as happy joyful go-lucky
optimistic and we're just generally
responsible for my thoughts and so over
time I've really had to work to
transition it and so is it here's the
one thing I found about anything that
you want to change it's gonna be if it's
if it's worth it it's gonna be difficult
yeah and it should be cool you know
you're in the right spot right it should
be hard it's it's not gonna be an
overnight thing otherwise it probably
wasn't that big of a deal yeah it's
probably not gonna change you that much
so I first started to identify first off
you have to recognize the pattern you
don't like anymore right you go okay I
don't like this pattern so something
might happen let's just take judgment
for an issue right like somebody walks
by and you're like oh he's this oh she's
that oh you know what something
judgmental first thing he goes I don't
want to be judgmental and say you go you
know what they probably you know they're
probably doing their best or you know
maybe they're struggling with this and
you start to take when you say oh you
say the judgmental thing in your head
and then you flip it and then eventually
over enough time of transitioning that
thought being you know your little
alchemist of changing the thought you
start having that thought of good more
regularly because you've practiced the
flip and then eventually you know you
get to a point where it that is the
dominant thought all the time but it's
hard like getting better is hard yeah it
is it isn't it's a consistent look you
got to you got to build routines and
habits in your life that actually make
you move in that direction right and
reading reading I hated read in high
school I didn't read anything in high
school they make they make a joke you
know my her my sister made it made a
joke they're like do you remember any
books that you read from high school
Mike yeah James and the Giant Peach
they're like Tony you read that in like
third grade
I'm like that's what everyone
my mom read The Lion the Witch and the
Wardrobe to me and she would look over
and she'd go
are you sleeping and I was totally
sleeping there's like no mom just
resting my eyes
enjoying a dream yeah so but like but
back to order of consequence that comes
from a book by Ray Dalio princesses so
phenomenal look another book talking
about like you know when somebody's
having a challenge like stopping and
thinking and going like hey what is this
person going through seven Habits of
Highly Effective People by Stephen Covey
hmm and you know he just real quick he
tells a story about how this guy was on
it he was on a train and this guy was on
the train with his kids and it's kid to
run around like crazy and you know he's
sitting there going like dude control
your kids like be a parent what are you
doing and he finally said something to
him and and the dad goes yeah he goes
you know he goes we just got back from
the hospital and their mom just passed
away and you know like and it totally
changes your perspective you're like
yeah you know yeah and it's like and he
said he goes he goes the kids don't know
how to handle it and I don't know he's
just I mean you're in shock he doesn't
know yet exactly he's in a state of
shock and you know when we stopped to
think about it because look I you know
New York we live in New York driving I
were driving here and coming across the
street how many times do we say see
people give people the finger you know I
don't know a lot but it's so funny like
just even driving like just giving
people the benefit of the doubt letting
people in you're not getting you're not
letting these little things frustrate
you to the point of where it's stealing
your joy and robbing you of your joy and
me I was probably the most negative
person on the planet and to see how far
I've come and just how we look at things
and how I look at things you could
change well you know we know it comes
from insecurities yeah it comes out of
them right you're your opinion of me is
a reflection of you not of me right all
right so if we're looking down the
street and we see something that we
judge it's probably because we judge it
within ourselves right so true very
powerful little thought process
but giving people the benefit of the
doubt means that you're giving yourself
the benefit of the doubt then - right
right that's just that's just a good
thing to do you talked about you know
ways to nurture and to change and
techniques so are there certain things
that you do that are you know daily
rituals are their practices are their
effort are there certain efforts that
you make whether it's like the books you
read or you know certain things that you
go to a like either what are your what
do you do to continue to grow and evolve
it's a good question what you say yeah
daily habits are everything that that's
it the small incremental choices that
you make are gonna ultimately lead to
your final result so yeah we we make
sure we're constantly our heads are in
books we don't set a specific we need to
read 15 minutes a day 20 minutes a day
but we are just constantly taking in
information through books through
podcasts or anything that feeds us
spiritually and emotionally and you know
mentally and gets us sharper you know
we're very careful about what we put
into our mind because we know that
that's what's gonna manifest into our
reality right I I believe you know most
people aren't truly conscious of that
when we became conscious of that it
changed everything yeah again back to
working out back to eating whatever you
put in your body
yeah that's whatever you feed yourself
that's what's going to eventually
manifest in the physical yeah well why
wouldn't it be the same thing whatever
you put into your mind is what's going
to come out and see out of your words
and out of your perception so we're
mindful of it whatever we're watching
whatever we were listening to whoever
we're associating with we want to make
sure that it aligns with whatever we
believe and what we want in our life you
know we kind of put it through a filter
does this align with our value system
and does this get us closer to our goal
if it doesn't match those two things
then why are we doing it mm-hmm right
so yeah so we're conscious about what we
put in and you know we make sure that we
we stay healthy you know we keep our
mind right
associations a really really big thing
as well and who we're aligning herself
with we always try to get us our selves
around people that stretch us mm-hmm you
know that grow us job that workout again
I'm just kidding used to be a trainer so
I think you need to put a smile you're
glad this morning man it will flash back
to its a pre pre Francis yeah but no
you're pretty intense by danika everyone
is really intense but we love it but we
are we're always getting ourselves
around people that that stretch us yeah
you know they're gonna if you a goldfish
is only gonna grow to the size of the
pond that it's in so is it true if you
put them in a bigger tank they would get
bigger yeah
yeah so it as human beings in our
evolution process and our expansion
process it's only natural if you're
gonna hang around with the same crowd
well then you can take the some of those
results and tell your cell you can
figure out what you're gonna be you know
projected 10 15 20 years down there just
say something like show me your five
friends and I'll show you yeah yeah yeah
so if you want a different result in
your life you know you're gonna have to
put yourself around people that are
gonna consistently sharpen the iron grow
and stretch you to become a better human
you know and it's uncomfortable and it's
not easy and just like the workout this
morning was easy but but it ultimately
makes you better and you're you're
you're more grateful for the for the
final result so yeah daily rituals are
key
you know meditation take I mean people
do all kinds of things take cold showers
in the morning whatever you have to do
to get yourself primed and ready for the
day so that because you're gonna
typically wake up in a negative state
the brain naturally it is always usually
typically going to gravitate towards the
negative because that's protection
mm-hmm it's kind of always probably
gonna look for what's wrong hmm
you know as you walk into a new
situation you're gonna survey the room
and you know it's a safe and you're
gonna look for maybe what's wrong in the
environment naturally if you're not
really in control of your thoughts just
said Oh
that a natural thing or is that a
learned thing like do we like based on
growing up do we just kind of get
trained to go make sure it's safe like
watch before you cross the road is this
a train thing or a train I think some of
it yeah I think a hundred thousand years
ago yeah probably just survival yeah I'm
running from the Lions in the open field
I don't know crazy stuff yeah
fortunately were dinosaurs real you know
fortunately we're not having to deal
with those kinds of those kinds of
threats in our life but our body is
wired to convergently look for settings
and to protect and preserve right so
when you wake up and your stream of
consciousness is going for most people
they wake up in a negative state yeah
you know that the fears of the day the
insecurities the doubts the what could
go wrong and so you have to grab hold of
your thoughts take them captive and and
get yourself in a prime state to speak
differently and look differently I've
been waking up I saw something that
someone did they said just wake up and
say thank you yeah and so wake up and
literally say that one word which I
could totally manage that as a practice
my ten minute made of meditation falls
by the wayside most of the time but I
can wake up and say thank you and it's
amazing the difference in your like
vibration yeah and trajectory then like
it's almost like you set the set like
you throw a dart in the morning and you
as soon as you let it go saying thank
you it's going forward it's going
towards positive yeah no absolutely and
really just living I think in a grateful
state is key you know one of the things
we do with our meditation is I will sit
there and visualize I'll do some
breathing exercises and then I'll
visualize well I'll give thanks for
whatever is currently in my life right
now that I whatever comes to me it could
it could literally be a bird that I hear
in the distance as I'm sitting there you
know hey thank you for this thank you
for the sunshine on my face
thank you for my daughter thank you for
my son thank you for my husband thank
you and I just go through this this
session of gratitude for the things I'm
currently thankful for in the present
moment yeah
then I give things for things in the
future Oh
man technique good job yeah I say
imagine it is it believe it and live it
and see it as if it's already happens if
it's already happen as if it are it is
it can only help but be then right yeah
so that's I'm giving thanks I'm
projecting out my goals the things that
you know whatever it is and I'm thinking
in advance for it to go smoothly and for
things to to happen to the way that I
alternate Li one and it's that
prostitute visualize that that end goal
that that thing is being thankful for
that yet has happened yet so I've heard
that's a very important which is for me
the most difficult part is to actually
visualize something realized because
your ego wants to say not yet girl like
you haven't done that yet don't be naive
that's what mind tells me anyway and so
it gets hard to do that but that isn't a
very important element of that
manifestation is not only the not only
saying it or you know thinking it but
but seeing it and believing right now I
remember when I was pregnant with my
daughter you know you you hear once
you're pregnant you get all the horror
stories of everything that could go
wrong know everybody wants to share
everyone was to share oh you know check
make sure you check on this make sure
you sure I'm not like mummy was yeah
like my sister's pregnant and I was like
ultrasounds just be really dangerous I'm
really bad and she ant and I was like I
almost don't want to send you this this
information it's like Instagram thing
and and she responded in the way and I
told her I'm like so glad you responded
this way she said okay I understand
she's like yeah I only get two and it's
not that big of a deal and I'm not gonna
stress about and like thank God because
I like my human you're like you want to
help people right but you know it can be
overwhelming and it you know they're
finding common ground with you they're
able to relate on their experience and
it's great you know and I love talking
to people about their experiences but
your first pregnancy it's a little bit
like so I would visualize Italy Ireland
that you don't know about and I'll see
you in nine months yeah totally but I
would just in my gratitude sessions I
would just visualize everything going
great and I would thankful in advance
for smooth pregnancy a smooth delivery a
healthy baby we had
the doctors telling us all sorts of
things about her development her brain
and we went through this little bit of
an emotional site rollercoaster with it
but we just we spoke life over it and we
spoke victory over it in advance that it
was already taken care of and everything
was gonna work out great and lo and
behold it did no you met her this
morning or you met her yesterday right
and she's so mad she's friggin awesome
and she count to ten and she's you know
18 months yeah what she was doing planks
and down-dog she was purling things like
she's lifting weights super smart little
kid and and you know any time we would
get reports like that we would just kind
of deny it rebuked it just you know we'd
pray about it and we just keep on moving
like we just didn't let those seeds of
doubt and negative just enter into our
like stick in our brain yeah
and we were just talking to Bill about
that who's one of our counselors and
he's helped us tremendously with our
marriage and whatnot and you know we
just so many people just receive
information and they just they hold on
to it and and it's easier to receive the
negative information all right then it
is the positive it's funny like you can
hear a hundred good things about you and
then you hear one bad thing and then one
thing right you know right so you know
that inside her brain you know quieting
that negative voice and not letting
basically suffocating that negative
voice and and growing that positive one
is so important and it does take time
yeah that's working where they're just
saying it's like the ego is impatient
because it knows it's time is limited
but the soul knows it has forever yep
and that's the thing is getting touch
more you know it kind of sounds silly
but we're really getting in touch with
your spirit and right yes you know just
your fleshly feelings well right cuz are
you I mean like Tony are you your arms
ya know are you your eyes even no no are
you your heart yeah no you're not any of
those things so what are you exactly
you're a conscious your your
consciousness your you're an energy
you're a spirit how or whatever you want
to call it makes you feel good that
follows along with what you believe but
yeah you're so true and so many people
are detached from that mm-hmm and they
only think of how they look you know or
how they're feeling that they like like
yeah when I started to understand this I
stopped being an emotional roller
coaster you know and you know so many
people
please help go ahead I had to be well
everything had to be perfect in my day
for me to quote-unquote feel good mmm
and then when I remember talking to Bill
and goes Tony goes you're gonna have a
day here and there where everything
falls in alignment and you feel good he
goes but those days are gonna be so far
and few between because you're gonna
live a miserable life I got the perfect
analogy yeah golf yeah it's almost
barely any time you go to golf you're
like every part of my game is on driving
fairway chipping putting yeah almost
never do you get all four parts of your
game together nope right that's life yep
golf but it's so true and when he said
that to me he goes told me you you have
to learn to not let your feelings
dictate how you're actually being and I
was like what what do you mean he goes
Tony if you don't feel good you have to
be able to control the feelings and
still enjoy your life he goes he goes
it's not he goes you're into this
destination disease where you think that
when you get to this point you're gonna
be happy he goes happiness is a choice
mm-hmm and you started talking to me
about it and you know we could talk two
hours just on this one point well point
is is is you have to stop being such an
emotional rollercoaster and it's
understanding that not everyone is gonna
be happy with what you're doing you know
question is are you happy with what
you're doing you know you're never gonna
be able to satisfy everybody or satisfy
you know your family and this and that
the question is is that the core of who
you are are you a good person are you
doing the right thing are you a person
of integrity do you truly treat people
the way you would like to be treated you
know like the basic golden rule yeah he
goes and if you do he goes there's gonna
be some people that will literally be
angry at how good you are to them he
goes but that's not you that's them he
goes and if you change who you are to
satisfy them
here's what happened he goes you will
lose yourself and you will never satisfy
them anyway that's true he goes so
figure out who you really really want to
be and and get down to the core of that
he goes and that's how your whole life
changes and that's what change in our
relationship I stopped being so like
like questioning what she said to me in
a negative way and being like did you
mean this and actually mean that and you
know I started going down rabbit holes
of course in security I talked about
this yesterday and well yard is filled
with rabbit holes yeah oh yeah of course
you know and it just it's it's it was
amazingly choice its voice yeah it's a
choice to decide whether or not you want
to feed that insecurity and run down
that rabbit hole rant and then as we
said before like you as a human will
like your mind will do everything and
anything possible to validate that crazy
thought yeah you will look like
Inspector Gadget in every nook and
cranny and every Instagram a crown
trying to figure out how you can justify
this crazy thought oh absolutely I
literally think of it as like a little
gremlin that's on your shoulder just
pulling your ears and getting you you
know yeah actually there's a great ELISA
romão is someone who is a spiritual
teacher and she has a whole chapter on
gremlins yep yeah yeah on and those
things can control your life for the
rest of your life yeah if you let them
well you know it's real if you believe
it yeah and and so it's about you
getting to the control panel you have
your life saying no you are in control
of your thoughts yeah your mind your
mind is a free agent it's gonna do
whatever the heck it wants it's gonna
look for whatever it wants to look for
and it's gonna craft whatever a picture
it wants to craft if you're not in
control and that's what most people
don't understand and that we didn't
understand for most of our life you know
and so we went through the experiences
that we went through and we actually did
something really interesting it's called
the Arno profiling system it's
temperament testing and it gets down to
the core of who you are it's it's pretty
deep it's it's a lot deeper than
personality testing and everything and
here's why your temperament is what
you're born with so you see two babies
in the nursery and they could look
totally different right
or just respond to the world totally
different we have a couple friends of
ours they have twins the girl is the
super feisty firecracker she's already
walking she's into things she's climbing
stuff like she's all over the place
mm-hmm the boys like super chill he's
just watches her he's like I'll walk
when I want to walk okay
I'll do what I want to do somebody bring
me my bottle and cool like doesn't cry a
whole lot super chill so they have their
temperaments their temperaments are
already visible you can see it yeah so
what happens as you go through life you
get this layer of conditioning over your
temperament and that comes from your
parents your teachers anybody that
influences you the experiences that you
have will condition and and start to
mold and shape you according to that if
you have super type-a parents but you're
like that little boy who's super chill
you're probably gonna act more
aggressive and type-a literally out of
survival in your own home even though it
goes against who you are then a third
layer of you is your personality and
that's what you want to be that's you
looking at somebody in the world and
seeing the results that they get and
wanting to emulate them because you want
to get the same result this isn't a
conscious thing that we all do but you
have a great coach you have a great you
know some anybody in your life a friend
of yours and you're like yeah they're
super extrovert and they're funny people
like you know if you're younger you're
like a guy you're like oh the girls so
whatever you know whatever it is that
you see you're like I like that
I want that result and therefore you
start acting like them yeah and that's
what shapes your personality but so by
the time you go through the conditioning
and the personality you could be so far
away from your temperament it's not even
funny and then and then you're you're in
the world going what's wrong with me why
do I get like this you know you compare
yourself to other people constantly
thinking like a man if I could just so
this test figures out the temperament
gets down to the Yama's
things that come after and goes hang on
let's get back to the root yes and it's
it's it's so enlightening and you guys
can use that the results were kind of
shocking right shocking totally shocked
because of because of our conditioning
yeah our personalities our temperaments
were somewhat opposite of what we
thought that we were
I was totally opposite yeah tony has
tony has what they call sanguine he's
sanguine melancholy he's got this super
fun relational side to him
that likes to have fun likes to be
spontaneous and then he's got this
melancholy side to him that's more
organized and things have to be it's
sort of a perfectionist it's like kind
of having a CPA and your brain as well
and that can also so you he can have
this sort of polar pool between the
sanguine jitters and likes to have fun
yeah and the melancholy side of him that
actually wants things a little more
quiet and can be somewhat more
introverted I on the other hand I have
I'm a choleric melancholy which means I
have basically like a lieutenant or
general in my head at all times
telling me that like I need to get stuff
done now so it's banging on my the door
of my mind consistently and then I've
got the melancholy the CPA that's like
yeah but if you're gonna do it do it
right like so it's so in other words
clerics if you have a straight choleric
and you're in a boardroom they're
usually the one pounding their fists on
the table hmm they're like oh we have to
do this you know they're there typically
they have a propensity to be leaders in
the world like they're they're typically
um just kind of out there they fling
stuff into the universe without even
like if they're straight choleric it
goes through no filter zero filter
that's because but because I have this
Oren Peli side I have got this filter
that's catching it so if I'm in a
boardroom I'm not the one banging my
fists but my brain is firing as if I am
yeah because I'm having this mental
conversation in my head that's figuring
out the right word figuring out the
right options and making sure that
whatever I say when I say it
powerhouse I'm usually the one that has
the last word yeah right so you can hang
it in this podcast I could be crazy
though if it's unregulated
yeah like if I don't if I'm not aware of
this I would I'd say up at night my
brain wouldn't shut off I would get
mentally exhausted I'd have low energy
at points because it was just like my
mind was on a consistent treadmill so
things like meditation and and just
sense of self-awareness and mindfulness
nature you and I talk Danica about
nature a lot it's it's not only
important it's essential vital yeah for
me I feel it's to stay grounded you know
and then the two of us entering to
entering into a relationship
we're versus it is it the melancholy
that allows it like is this some kind of
a test that you could do to say like
yeah we're compatible you actually
because we wouldn't have been but it
would definitely help 1000 percent fish
couples took it before they were going
into a relationship I mean we do not us
but yeah you know we set up one of the
parts of our mentorship organization
that you know has a part with these
people people could get tested I bet
people wouldn't want to do it I bet if
people were in a relationship they
wouldn't want to do it cuz I don't think
it was very good that sounds great no it
doesn't what if it doesn't come back the
way I want well and that is the fear of
truth than people have right because
you're gonna get there anyway yeah if
you're not meant to be if it's not meant
to be move along because it's going to
happen anyway and all it does is get
more difficult more complicated and more
painful yeah so face the truth as soon
as humanly possible that's something
that I've you know I do the best job I
possibly can with is facing the truth as
soon as possible it's like oh if you
don't like this well I better do that
sooner or later because if that's the
problem then it's gonna come out sooner
it's something else will be the reason
the venture later you know yeah so
that's it that's a fantastic cess I'll
sign up I'm sure I'm sure
oh you like it yeah you and I talked
about that yeah yeah yeah and if a
couple took it before they were really
entering in a relationship it wouldn't
it wouldn't say hey you guys are
compatible or not good so it's like a
psychic they're never going to
Dyson's gonna be you should really be
careful about the train but what I'll do
is it would give the the couple
tremendous perspective on how the other
one operates its tools yeah and how they
think if we want to know our
relationship knowing because because
that was the biggest thing this is a
miscommunication yes sir understanding
yeah yeah so she would do things I don't
like the heck what is that I would do
things that she'd be like what is wrong
with you you know and and the other
thing was I was so insecure with how I
was actually being because so much of my
conditioning growing up you know not to
go into too a long explanation but like
I would have these big explosions with
my family with friends with loved ones
and I created a pattern where it would
be a fight wouldn't get resolved until
it got to a ridiculously high elevated
state so then that became my idea what
you mean yeah yeah yeah so then that
became my pattern and I brought that
into all my relationships and until I
was able to understand my temperament
and then understand where this pattern
came from I wasn't able to disconnect
the button from like like literally
people would push my buttons and would
take me there yeah so I had to
disconnect the wiring from the button
yeah you know and get to the root pull
it out and yeah you know look it in the
face and go no more yep you change
patterns or change routines or and just
change your firing you had to go to some
neuroplasticity of retraining your brain
and I think that this is something that
if everyone was honest they would want
to do Oh owner person and I think every
I think there is some sort of level of
compatibility with all of the
temperaments yeah because we have seen
them we have so many people now that
have taken a test and and we've seen the
results so we've seen so many that you
know it's funny if they're if they're if
they have the exact same temperament
usually what they'll struggle with is is
awareness because they're the same so
like they're not gonna call each other
out on anything so if you know if
something if somebody else offends them
they're both gonna be like yeah that
person's wrong well because they're both
coming from
the same perspective so it that can
actually be kind of tough yeah you know
for them operating in the rest of the
world around them because they're both
justifying each other's wrongs
essentially we were very opposite in a
lot of categories even though we had
that melancholy it that it's broken down
into three categories inclusion which is
how you are socially control which is
control how you want to control yourself
and others and then affection which is
you know how you relate to other human
beings and want that sense of affection
so we are we were different in each
category and for the affection category
in particular I'm not even on the scale
he's off the scale right so that right
there that right there for a
relationship can be could be challenging
if we if he would get offended or get
get his feelings for it hurt in a sense
because I wasn't responding to him a
certain way that he thought everybody
should respond to everybody that way
because that's how I am right we give
what we want to get yeah yeah yeah yeah
so what what it did is it broke down
these barriers for us and we just
learned to accept who we were you know
and and but also not you know accept our
temperaments and learn the strengths
understand the weaknesses but not give
justifications for them just know that
they're there and and know now be
excited about what we have to improve on
but we shed grace on each other we had
empathy can you went to the positive
yeah and now we get it like you like
your clerical got it you gotta handle
this you're so good at this so you can
focus on the positive and how it could
be used to your advantage instead of
being frustrated or or letting the ego
scream out loud like are you telling me
I'm not good enough are mine odd detail
or not perhaps whatever may be the
problem what a what a cool thing I'm
again like I said I would love to do it
I think that's a innovative and like if
we can use science we might as well know
so that's cool look I I want to finish
off this conversation by one of the
points that we got to in the middle
which is your first chapter I want you
guys to tell me what you want said at
your funeral about you as a human being
this is good I'm gonna go first sure
sure
you know I that that us living a life
that we impacted people tremendously
positive that people lived a better life
because we were a part of it and we
connected them with the right people and
we helped them in certain areas of their
life and that you know we we generated
or helped charities and have charities
with huge trust funds that live on way
beyond our days and and that that we are
making an impact way past our death date
that's what we want that we always that
no matter how difficult it was at points
we always stood on the side of right
whether it was you know unpopular
whether it was - you know a lot of
people only do things what's right when
it's in their financial best interest or
when it's not offending anyone we don't
we do the thing that's right no matter
what and if somebody doesn't like it too
bad if we lose money on it well that's
okay because we believe that doing the
right thing is the right thing no matter
what and I think so many people there's
a great simple book called the go giver
and you know the beginning of the book
the guy is his perspective on how to
make it in the world is to basically
kind of do do whatever you have to do to
stomp on your competition and beat out
your person and in that site it becomes
a test of all and you know the mentor in
the book really teaches him that's not
the way to do it and that's not the way
to live because at the end of your life
man if you made all this money and all
the success and everything but you burn
relationship you hurt people you did the
wrong thing working out of fear instead
of love yeah yeah the heck did you what
was your life yeah you know um Tony
Robbins talks about it with the Dickens
method you know Charles Dickens and you
know the Christmas Carol Christmas Carol
yeah yeah every needs of Scrooge going
through that process of you know his
life being you know presented to him you
know what people are gonna say you know
how he's affecting people in the present
and how he was brought up in in the past
and you know it's like we don't never
look at our lives like that most people
don't and they when they're doing the
wrong thing we justified people justify
why it's okay to do the wrong thing and
a long time ago we just stopped
justifying stuff like that
first-first yourselves yeah other people
we were just like no this is wrong
and we are gonna do everything you know
we're just not going to do that we're
not gonna go down that road we're not
gonna justify things and and when you do
that you you live so like we put our
head on our pillow at night and we know
we're doing the right thing and here's
the thing we don't just go we're doing
the right thing right we check with
people we're always in Council we have a
multitude of counselors that will hold
us accountable to a ridiculously high
standard yeah because a lot of people I
heard one you know you know one person
said oh well I counsel with God really
you talk to anyone else also you have a
direct phone line with God because
that's ridiculous because you could you
could have somebody you know okay you
could be a wacko and say you're talking
to God
it's a looped conversation possibly yeah
it is exactly exactly and and you may
not be godly you can't connect with some
spirit agree and the intuition or gut
feeling or whatever you want to say but
look your your cop out of like it's just
that one person we have a good
conversation and it's fine like it's
it's part of the team but exactly god is
definitely part of the team but then God
will speak through you through other
people as well so if you're if you don't
have other people in your life that are
holding you to accountable to the
standard of which you quote-unquote say
you want to live then you're full of
crap
so find people in life that are going to
hold you to that standard and kick butt
yeah you know so that's yeah and I think
it's on that point you can make God
whatever you want it to be based upon
your intentions and experience I'm not
saying I'm not saying that that's that
that's right I'm just saying that's what
people can do yeah so they can twist
whatever story they they want projected
into the world and use that because no
one can go verify it nobody can go in
fact check or check the record base
right and crafts whatever story they
want so we can do that too if we're not
careful you know we can we have to
really be in your arches closed loop of
saying like you good you go yeah we're
all we're doing right I think sure yeah
you can absolutely talk yourself into
whatever you know so we do seek and 100%
and we we look for that to be our true
north with our spiritual connection but
then we check it with counselors with
wise counselors
so I got the I got the front-row seat so
the funeral experience when I lost my
dad in 2008 and that's when everything
shifted for me that's when I had my
existential crisis if you will and I
started to reevaluate everything I was
doing why was I doing it what did I
actually believe in because my dad was
my hero he's my best friend and he was
also our lifeline to our family you know
so financially and everything that our
lives just started to change
dramatically but at his funeral
I was really impacted by by the fact
that when people were sharing whatever
they wanted to share it wasn't about the
credits or the credentials some of the
accolades my dad had you know his story
was inspiring he came from nothing he
made something of himself he did a lot
of really great things he won a lot of
awards he contributed to books nobody's
up there saying you know that this
particular book on supply chain
management or this you know we're so
proud of him for that everything that
they were sharing came down to some sort
of investment that he made into them
through time through friendship through
telling them the truth about something
that they needed to hear even when they
didn't he didn't want to hear it because
he loved them more than he cared about
their opinion of you know or their
feelings right he was that kind of guy
and and so so many people are impacted
that people flew in from all across the
United States people we've never even
met before that wanted to tell us a
story about our dad and and he was just
it hit me so so loudly that up until
that point in my life I was very
performance driven you know I was
chasing musical theater that's what
everything was about I didn't care who
was in my way you're gonna get the heck
out of my way for me to get to my goal
and not that you can't be so passionate
and focused and determined on something
absolutely but if you're doing it at the
expense of relationships and really
experiencing life again what are you
doing it for right
it's that destination oriented disease
that I that I had and so I shifted my
perspective and I said when I get
to the end of my life I want people to
have said as Tony mentioned my life is
better off because of Francis in some
sort of way of Tony and Francis in some
sort of way they contributed to our life
they impacted our life they they they
went out of their way to serve us when
nobody else would
you know they they're the kind of people
that you know just would have given
their shirt off their back and done
anything for us and in terms of our
relationships and our friendships and
anything that we just sew into the world
we want to make sure it's good and we're
proud of it and by the time we get there
we can back and say hey job well done I
want to get to the finish line exhausted
I literally want my hair messy sweaty
just like out of breath kind of like I
was this morning but I just the finish
line of our life I just want to just get
there just like yeah you know and it'd
just be like hey man job well done
you did it you you went from you you
achieved your highest potential and and
you made the world better you know I
know you know it may not be eradicating
malaria or doing something necessarily
on that level where the whole world
feels it but as far as we can reach the
goal wanna make an impact absolutely
well here's to building bridges not
burning them and if we just build enough
bridges we connect everyone in the world
so yep
thank you guys for having thank you for
deeper more meaningful a very meaningful
purpose and to give yourselves and your
time and your emotion to see people help
see the best in themselves I love that
too I'm sure that I show that um that
that goal in life so thanks for thanks
for all the sacrifice and the vision and
thinking outside the box
screw the box yeah exactly no thank you
and thanks for everything you're doing
down we love how you're showing up in
the world like you you know you kicked
butt you're such like I mean you're your
legend you're a legend you're
you're a hero you're a mentor to so many
and your your it's not over for you it's
never over like you're just stepping
into a new arena yeah and just getting
started on something that I know is
gonna impact not just tens of thousands
of people but hundreds of thousands of
people worldwide well thank you I'm not
the best at receiving compliments so I'm
working on that too always a work in
progress yeah well thanks guys very much
thank you thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it and also
thank you so much Trevor Hall for the
awesome music if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button
[Music]